today I'll show you how to get alerts on
changes to your system I would like to
get an email anytime someone creates a
VM instance in my project in stock
driver logging select GCE VM instance
and then select activity now you can see
all the audit logs on my GCE resources
if I expand this one I see that the
method name is compute instances insert
which is a VM create so I'm going to
show matching entries just to see my
create logs in order to get an alert I
need to create a metric and name my
metric and then I click create metric
now I go to stack driver monitoring and
click create an alert policy I add a
condition using a metric threshold and
my resource type in this case is going
to be log metrics I can select my
user-defined metric here set a threshold
and then save the condition I said I
wanted to be notified so I'm going to
setup an email notification I could also
use SMS a web hook or the app or any of
the other notification methods available
and stackdriver monitoring I'm going to
name my policy and then I'll save the
policy now if someone creates a VM
instance I will get an email